amelia hamlin and scott disick have
split she's 19. he's 37 with three kids
hello a source tells et that the couple
has called it quits with amelia staying
in new york to attend fashion week and
scott returning to la keeping busy with
work and staying distracted while
amelia's mom lisa rena is probably
relieved by the breakup i am a little
nervous about it i'm a lot nervous about
it a source previously told et that her
daughter is feeling hurt by the
situation the situation well it was that
whole alleged leaked dm thing let's
break it down last week scott allegedly
dm'd his ex kourtney kardashian's ex
eunice benjamin to shade court's pda
with her current boyfriend travis barker
scott allegedly wrote to eunice yo is
this chick okay bro like what is this in
the middle of italy eunice posted the
alleged dm along with his response to
scott writing doesn't matter to me as
long as she's happy p.s i ain't your bro
he also added a note to the screenshot
writing quote keep the same energy you
had about me publicly privately which is
possibly a nod to what scott and the
kardashian said about him during the
keeping up with the kardashians reunion
special the last guy let's all be honest
nobody was happy with the last one
really yeah scott and everyone else
i was still there to try to help her
through as source previously told dt
that scott was trying to write the
situation off as nothing but as the days
went by amelia was more and more hurt by
the whole thing the source adds that the
20 year old model had been understanding
of scott's co-parenting routine and the
family dynamic but this disappointed her
oh my god since then amelia has
seemingly expressed her thoughts on
social media by posting a tank top pick
that reads don't you have a girlfriend i
really think that that's another
question mark and on top of that
amelia's mom couldn't help but post a
photo of harry styles which makes sense
as she said this on real housewives of
beverly hills like why can't it be harry
styles why
is it scott disick other sources
previously told et that disick was salty
about his ex's new relationship with a
blink 182 drummer but is a little
embarrassed that he reached out to
eunice and that he posted their exchange
and that's it as for courtney who shares
three kids with scott a separate source
told dt that she and travis don't care
about scott's opinion but courtney is
upset it's now public
courtney doesn't want her kids seeing
anything online that makes it look like
their parents don't get along courtney
has always been conscious of being
private in past relationships but she's
done caring what others think and is
enjoying love with travis i'm just like
living life and
whatever happens happens
[Music]